[Musik]
so ist jetzt wirklich eine neue wohnung
natürlich nicht aber ich interessiere
mich für die angebot
mal schauen was es so gibt die so schön
findest du was kostet die wohnung 1200
euro kaltmiete inklusive nebenkosten
sind das bestimmt 1500 euro was
politikern in einem kleinen vorort sehr
ruhige lage bauernhöfe in der nähe
also springt in der stadt stinkt es die
wohnung ist doch süß dachgeschoss
teilweise immobilien 60 quadratmetern
550 euro damit muss man dann kaum
bezahlen
sicher zwei kaltmieten das kann gut
willst du eine besichtigung vereinbaren
nein ich habe doch gesagt dass ich nur
schauen manchmal muss man eine
gelegenheit ergreifen
ja manchmal sagt die gelegenheit auch
ich erstelle dir keine webseite weil du
nicht wichtig genug bist familie ist mir
wichtig ach ja ja und ich kann es dir
beweisen wie denn ich habe einen job für
nico
ein job ja und ich wollte dich fragen ob
du mich ob ich es ihm sage ja auf keinen
fall
ich mag mir heute nicht zu aber ich
finde dass du selbst versuchen muss ist
ein guter job ist dann wird er die auch
zu hören
[Musik]